all right the border is still a mess uh
better than 2 million as you know a
record number of migrants Crossing into
this country that doesn't include likely
the hundreds of thousands of so-called
gotaways but the administration seems to
be focused on a very different number
the roughly 24 000 Venezuelans trying to
get here uh and trying to Reign at least
that number in especially since a
disproportionate number of Venezuelans
uh like the claim Asylum to ease their
way here or at least get the menier to
adjudicate their case uh Joseph Ariel
joins us right now the Rio Grande City
Texas Mayor mayor this subset of the the
migrant population coming in to the
country and the fact the administration
uh is focusing on that I I'm sure you
would welcome any focus on on the border
and anyone trying to get in here but but
that contingent what do you think
well good morning thank you for having
me on your program and uh
we must call it for what it is and uh
this is Biden's rendition of remain in
Mexico 2.0 and ironically Biden is
following Trump's lead which by the way
remained in Mexico is highly effective
in managing large influxes of migrants
and currently we are experiencing record
numbers of apprehensions over 2.2
million now the flip side is that remain
in Mexico is not a permanent solution
for our broken immigration system
however it is beneficial when our
migrant processing capabilities are
overextended and compromised and
consequently jeopardizing our national
security so absolutely there is a
component there and we must address our
broken immigration system and I know
we've had these conversations before but
nonetheless at this point is it too
little too late I don't know bottom line
this is something that we need to
address as a country we need to address
our Asylum laws our immigration laws our
Visa programs in fact Visa overstays
account for almost half of the
population living in the US illegally
and we have close to a million Visa
overstays annually so bottom line there
is something that we must we need to do
and unfortunately we haven't done it
thus far and I know we've had this
conversation that both political parties
have failed to prioritize our broken
immigration system and uh but bottom
line we need to take action not words
not promises not rhetoric action and not
as uh Browns blacks are wise not as
Republicans Or democrats but as
Americans and carefully manage the
balance between immigration and border
security which can mutually coexist we
just haven't found the the middle ground
yeah you're probably right about that
but does Mexico need to take action as
well do you think they help uh in this
process uh as you know they're not keen
on this idea that a lot of these
Venezuelans and their cases are going to
be handled in Mexico which is you
rightly pointed out uh does seem to be
going back to the policy under the Trump
years but I am curious as to whether you
think they're they're making this
situation worse I mean after all you
know the overwhelming number of migrants
who make their way to our side of the
Border uh first make their way to the
southern side of the Mexican border uh
from Guatemala and Point South and and
it doesn't appear that Mexico does
anything to stop that
well we must work with Mexico and the
northern triangle countries to counter
these human trafficking operations and
gather intelligence and Mexico is
willing to be a partner in this however
we need to absolutely sit down with them
and have that conversation because there
are many elements to this that benefits
both countries so it is something that
Mexico is conversations haven't we mayor
we have the concept I'm just wondering
do they ignore us or maybe things are
being done behind the scenes that I'm
unaware of but are they doing as much as
they could be doing
at this point I don't know what the
conference said because again you said
there have been conversations but what
exactly that they have the conversations
on I don't know honestly I don't know
the information however
the people that I've worked with by the
way I do make many trips to Mexico and I
with my counterparts here Mayors in in
Camargo Mila Le mansortas and we sit
down and have the conversations and
guess what both we have mutual uh
understandings of what needs to happen
here at the border and they do share
many of the same concerns security
safety tourism come Commerce and and
guess what they're willing to work with
us I work very well and closely with the
Mayors here and right across the border
here in Rio Grande City so honestly I do
not see why the governors or the
president of Mexico would not have or
open to the conversation of sitting down
and working this out because Mexico
benefits too by having a good working
relationship with the US you're talking
about billions of dollars in trade and
every consumable commodity and service
with destination anywhere USA here in
their own two-way or two-lane uh Bridge
here it's over billion dollars in trade
and that's just one single bridge but we
have so much so many opportunities that
we can certainly work with Mexico and
this is one of them and they are open to
this idea that we need to address
immigration and uh absolutely have a
hold on it because if we're not we're
going to continue to have these issues
now another thing by the way and this is
imperative that we address too according
to the U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics
employment is projected to increase by
12 million jobs so right now we have
also the opportunity to address both
issues immigration and the future crisis
which will be labor shortages it's going
to be a point
we've got to act we got to act on this
to your point mayor thank you I wish we
had more time sir but it's always good
having you I appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else